hello and welcome to spectators cop 26
summit i'm fraser nelson editor of the
spectator we're counting down the day to
cop 26. so what better time to discuss
some of the key themes that are going to
come up in today's pac schedule my
colleagues kate andrews and cindy you
will be discussing everything from
nuclear energy to the individual actions
to contribute to tackling climate change
we'll have mps journalists lords
lifestyle gurus and of course our two
sponsors for today edf energy and smart
energy but to get started i'm delighted
to welcome our keynote speaker for today
anybody who is trying to read up in
climate change signs will know of dieter
helm he is the perhaps the world's
leading authority in making sense of us
all his book net zero and his numerous
writings on this frame much of people's
general understanding he is not a huge
fan of cop summits arguing that they
tend not to make much difference over
the years does he think this one is
going to be any different i'm delighted
now to welcome dj helm these are over to
you thank you very much fraser and thank
you very much for the invitation to kick
off your uh very important
sessions today
um i want to
paint a big picture
because
it is a big picture we have to look at
climate change is a global problem
and much as people might get terribly
excited about the emissions in
particular towns and villages in bits of
the united kingdom or elsewhere the fact
is that a ton of carbon emitted anywhere
is the same as a ton of carbon emitted
emitted anywhere else
what we have to do is get the global
emissions down and the same applies to
sequestration because the
crucial
variable which people tend not to talk
about at things like cop is the
concentration of carbon in the
atmosphere you know the problem getting
this right is actually quite simple and
straightforward we have
a bunch of greenhouse gases and i use
the proxy of carbon in the atmosphere
they create a blanket around the globe
and
they are responsible for the greenhouse
effect which is as the uh energy from
the sun comes in the greenhouse effect
blanket uh captures uh and holds some of
that heat
so what really matters
indeed the only variable that matters is
the carbon concentration in the
atmosphere
and that's the product of sequestration
the natural world soaking up carbon and
emissions by the natural world and
ourselves
so this is a problem about getting that
concentration down or at least stopping
it going up by sequestration
and the land in particular and also by
reducing emissions
now you might think that after one cop
and another
you know from the original kyoto
protocol
to the copenhagen fiasco through to the
durban summit paris and now glasgow
that with all that uh intellectual
scientific
moral political goodwill and capital
devoted to this problem
after 30 years we'd have made some
progress
but the reason i wrote my book
and the reason i'm exercised about
whether cop is really well focused is
that we haven't made any progress at all
in preventing the increase
every single year since 1990 of two
parts per million of carbon in the
atmosphere
every single year not a dent in that
increase two parts per million plus
every year to the point where about 150
percent
of the
pre-industrial revolution levels
and you know remarkably we added two
parts per million last year despite all
the lockdowns around the world because
the coronavirus we added two parts per
million when uh the great financial
crisis hit in 207 208.
so the question is what are we doing
about that
now here in the uk
we pride ourselves or rather the prime
minister prides himself on the idea that
we're world leaders in reducing carbon
emissions
doesn't say we're world leader it
leaders in making impact on the carbon
concentration the atmosphere because
that's a very different story
and if you look at what's happened in
the uk economy we've de-industrialized
with 80 services we import a great deal
and if you
go down that process of closing down
your industrial production your energy
intensive production and import it from
places like china well the result is
going to be that you may well reduce
your own emissions and look extremely
good
and be able to boast to all the
participants at glasgow what a great
success we are but you might actually be
increasing climate change
because a ton of steel produced in port
talbot probably has less carbon content
than a ton of steel import produced in
china and imported back into the uk so
if you look at the big picture
what's really been going on is the
enormous growth of emissions from china
which is now nearly 30 percent of the
world's emissions
and the apparent reduction of emissions
in europe in the uk and to extend to the
united states
and the balance of that and the trade
that goes with that produces this
outcome that we add two parts per
million per annum every single year
and when you trace this through this has
an implication about how we describe
climate change and what we as
individuals should be doing
so if we unilaterally
as one small country in the world decide
that we unilaterally are going to stop
causing climate change
we have to make sure
that our carbon footprint is going down
and not simply a territorial carbon
production which is what the targets for
cops etc are all about
and that means that we must treat
imports
the beef from the cleared amazon uh
imports from of chinese steel of cement
petrochemicals fertilizers and so on we
must treat them in exactly the same way
as we treat home production they should
all pay
implicitly or explicitly the price of
the emissions that go
into their production then you get a
very different story
because if we genuinely want to say
we are no longer causing climate change
it's not true when we get to net zero
that that will hold despite what the
climate change committee claimed despite
what the prime minister claims we will
only unilaterally be no longer causing
climate change
if we are at net zero carbon production
and that comes to the
uh
crucial point
about who actually causes climate change
the truth is it's you and me
we have this habit of thinking it's all
the fault of those dirty oil companies
those horrible gas companies and were
still those preposterously bad
coal companies it's industry that causes
all this
no
industry produces the stuff for you and
me
ultimately the economy is for us and
it's our consumption which feeds through
into climate change and it's our
consumption that has to be decarbonized
so when it's put about through the kind
of cakerus cakist argument but you know
it's going to cost you anything you'd
have to change your lifestyle no hair
shirts here any of that stuff
this is not really true
the truth is that we have to look quite
hard at what that consumption is if we
want to unilaterally no longer cause
climate change and in my book i suggest
the way to think about that problem
is to write down your carbon diary
so
start the day just jot down the things
you do and have a hazard of a guess at
how much carbon's involved
i can tell you it's a lot by the way 80
percent of the world's energy is fossil
fuels right and that energy goes into
producing virtually everything that you
consume but especially the stuff that
you import
and you'll realize that if you now want
to rewrite that diary in 250 with no
carbon in it
or at least
any carbons in it fully offset that's a
radical change in your lifestyle
and what that really tells you is that
we are the polluters we live beyond our
environmental means and we have to get
part back on a sustainable path and then
of course economic growth is perfectly
possible because technical progress
takes place all sorts of new ideas and
inventions come about
but there's no free lunch here
that i think is absolutely essential
when we think about all the posturing
that we'll have a cop 26 so i think we
should measure the right thing which is
the carbon concentration in the
atmosphere and we should set targets for
our carbon consumption our true carbon
footprint if we unilaterally want to
make no further contribution and by the
way just to square it off if we really
did charge the same price of carbon on
imports as domestically that would
bottom up produce a coalition of the
willing because of course if you're
chinese and you're exporting the uk and
you have to pay a carbon border price
you will obviously ask the question how
do i get out of it and the answer is
pretty straightforward have an
appropriate carbon price domestically at
home and then we're on the same level
playing field so i'm in favor of a
bottom-up coalition of the willing
genuinely no longer causing climate
change and gradually proliferating
around the world
rather than having a grandstand idea
that if everybody stands up and says
they're going to be net zero and 250
this is somehow magically going to solve
our problems
so that's the frame in which i look at
these problems and of course there's an
enormous amount of
detail consideration of the component
parts but let me stop at that
thanks very much indeed and these are
now and you mentioned um hair shirts
there i imagine that's a reference to
the prime minister's preface to the
government's plans to meet net zero
which they launched last week there was
quite a striking passage there which i
i'd like to to read out and ask your
thoughts on and for years boris johnson
says going green was inextricably bound
with a sense that we had to sacrifice
the things that we love
but this strategy shows how we can build
back greener without so much as a hair
shirts in sight
in other words he
says it's false to say he's saying that
going green means sacrifice losing the
things that we love
you're saying but that's untrue and we
should confront the fact that going
green will mean higher bills in some
cases very high very
very much higher bills and a
corresponding decline in living
standards
i think that the
deceit
in the climate change dialogue at the
political level
is based upon the idea
that you must tell the public
that they're going to be better off and
you don't tell them that they're
responsible for any of the environmental
damage that's done
so think about it simply in an efficient
economy is one that includes all the
costs we're not paying the costs of the
carbon emissions that we're causing or
only paying some of them and therefore
we are polluting beyond any optimal or
sensible level and we have to get that
down
and you just have to look at the
lifestyles that people pursue
and ask yourself how compatible are they
with protecting the biodiversity and the
uh uh
carbon uh position the climate and the
answer is they're not very so what we
have to do is get back onto a
sustainable growth path and i say growth
pop because it doesn't mean that we have
to have living teepees i'm very much
with the uh prime minister on this but
it does mean that we have to make some
pretty substantial adjustments and if
you look at the bits that are going to
perhaps hurt a bit
like
getting gas boilers out of houses
you know the answer is well we then
actually tell people that it's going to
be you know 10 000 a house and you're
going to have to pay it
so we say well we'll make taxpayers
contribute to that but we're all
taxpayers
so i just think it's naive i think it's
bad economics and ultimately i think
it's really bad politics and bad
environmentalism because it will be
found out after all remember what
happened when we discovered a month or
two ago that we had no solution to the
backup of intermittency of wind
imagine if you're on below average
income and you're receiving one of those
bills on your doorstep or electronically
at the beginning of october and then
you're going to get another 15
in april next year does that sound like
a free lunch
right well perhaps not but when i talk
to government ministers about this uh
and they say they say something to me
off the record they said didn't say on
the record but it's still like your
thoughts in it there's a huge amount of
faith optimistic faith in tory circles
but technology will come along and bail
us out now they say but look at the
things that are happening now ten years
ago nobody would have dreamt that elon
musk's tesla could be worth a billion
dollars nobody would have thought that
the cost of generating wind power would
be down at a strike price of of 35
dollars per megawatt megawatt hour
nobody would have thought that the
advanced and solar the advanced
renewables would be as fast fast forward
this process another 20 years
and we can see technology coming to make
these things possible and therefore the
trade-offs that you mentioned might be
regarded as old-fashioned so what are
your thoughts on that about the about
the speed of technological innovation
and the likelihood of this innovation
coming up with lowering perhaps even
eliminating the cost of net zero
so the first thing to say is that
of course we're going to need
technologies right so the the the the
line that was trotted out over the last
decade was we already had all the
technologies we needed we didn't need
anything new to get to 250 and so called
net zero okay turns out not to be true
turns out to be that we need quite a lot
of new technologies and the great news
is they're coming okay so you know my
university what uh the bright young
graduates want to do is they want to
work on new technologies for addressing
climate change great
okay
um but it doesn't follow from the fact
that we're going to hopefully address
quite a lot of these problems that there
are no costs
of uh
in the process of getting from here to
there it's both
okay and let me put it to you this way
if you really wanted to make the economy
efficiently drive towards new
technologies you'd put in a price of
carbon that price of carbon will be
whatever level is necessary to achieve
the target
and if you tell me that that price would
not have any impact on the standard of
living then i think you're deluded i
think it's just not true right so it's
both it's not technology will solve
everything you know but it's not
technology won't make any difference
it's there's a balance in here we have
to get on a sustainable growth path and
it's not by magic and if you really
believed that the technology is going to
solve all this law or just abolish all
the substance get rid of them you don't
need any subsidies if you know
renewables is really cheaper than other
forms of generation you know for example
and take the wind issue which i'm very
much in favor of wind particularly
offshore wind but you know it's not true
that its price is 30 pound a megawatt
hour that's not paying for the
intermittency if you want to know the
price of wind add back in the price of
gas you're currently paying when the
wind doesn't blow and that's why when i
did the cost of energy review i set out
that you'd have to have what i call
equivalent firm power options and if you
do that the rating of offshore wind
nuclear and a lot of other technologies
would look quite remarkably different
from the ones that are presented to us
if you don't include the intimacy costs
you don't include the networks you don't
include the wires etc you will get a
very low number but it's just not true
so if renewables are intimate and this
they can't be relied upon and and you're
saying in the last few weeks ago we all
confronted the the fact that you know
the wind wasn't blowing with a bit of an
energy crisis
what about nuclear isn't it simply isn't
this the great elephant in the room that
people aren't talking about so from what
i gather the nuclear industry isn't even
allowed to exhibit in cop26 because the
green groups are against it um
and i put to you that our choice is
either fossil fuels
energy crisis or nuclear one of those
three
i don't think there's any silver bullet
to this
my guess is that we'll need all of these
things
okay and there are no
pure
virtuous carbon-free ways of generating
electricity full stop they all have
problems
so if you look at offshore wind it's the
question of the intermittency it's the
question of being low
um
energy forms uh and it's about networks
and backup and so on we'll have new
technologies like battery storage
etcetera coming along uh
smart uh demand side etc all of those
things are coming if you look at nuclear
there are
obviously issues to address
when the famous flowers royal commission
looked at nuclear in 76 it said there
should be no new nuclear until there is
a satisfactory solution to nuclear waste
now it's true that modern nuclear power
stations don't produce as much waste as
in our old magnoxes our aral magnets is
by 1990 to produce more nuclear waste
than the rest of the world's nuclear
industry put together but it's also a
responsibility to address those
questions and it's legitimate of people
to ask questions about that and then
there's the cost per unit if you want to
do nuclear do it properly that's what
i've always argued right you know france
was building six nuclear power stations
simultaneously at one stage when it
built 50 plus of these things
right we produce one wait another five
years dither and then think we might
produce another one well actually we
started off with saying let's try three
different sorts and see which one works
you know that's not how you do nuclear
power so on the nuclear front it's
almost certainly part of the frame
it's got issues to address like the
other technologies
but you know the crucial thing with
nuclear is do it properly and it's not
just an economic question the lifespan
of the waste the term structure of these
plants always involve social and
political frames for them and that's
what the government has to think through
in order to
push this particular part as one
component of the overall energy frame
right so just um to follow up on that so
you're saying that the french were
building five or six at any one time we
moved gingerly we came up with pinky
points you know then we wasted while we
do it again do you think we should right
now be building three or four nuclear
plants not just simply looking at some
hindi points
i think we should either do a nuclear
program
or not
okay i think the thing about nuclear
which is different from do we had a wind
farm here at a wind farm there is that
uh it
is a scale issue
it has all sorts of supply chain issues
associated with it it's big enduring and
um uh
you know the original plan was to have
four of these things remember it's a
twin reactor at hinckley and a proposed
twin reactor at size well but you know
either do it or if you're not going to
do it
then think through the consequences so
take a country that decided not to do
nuclear which is germany which is about
the most uh uh
in a carbon sense polluting country in
europe it's not green it's very brown so
he decided he didn't want to do nuclear
in order to have the greens as part of
the coalition back in 2000 and then
subsequently did various u-turns until
merkel really pulled the plug on
existing nuclear as well as new nuclear
it built 13 gigawatts of coal
and it has serious issues about how to
back up the system you know if you want
to have a wind only system which many
environmentalists do or an
overwhelmingly wind system there's
nothing inherently wrong with that but
you do have to solve the problem what
are you going to do about the
intermittency and what are you going to
do about the base load now curiously
nuclear plus wind does not solve the
intermittency problem
that remains
and therefore um perhaps unfortunately
it's inevitable that we'll have to have
renewables
we may have nuclear but we'll also have
to have a transitionary fuel and that's
where we have to get a bit more grown up
about gas and about how that gets us
from here to a world in which we've got
other ways of handling that
intermittency
did britain make a mistake in not going
for fracking in the way that we could
have done say 10 12 years ago
no
um but not for the reasons that many
people think
frankly if you look at the geology in
the uk
and its sheer complexity and compare it
with the geology in the permian basin
and elsewhere in the united states
you know it's never going to be
particularly economic look at the dense
populations and all the practical things
that are involved in access accessing
these kinds of sites i just think it
wasn't an economic proposition you know
the real question is should you do
fracking in the us in argentina in parts
of russia and in the middle east and
that's
got a cost structure that's completely
different
and just remember in all of this you
know when we get very excited about some
of this stuff you know obama provide
presided over the greatest expansion of
fossil fuels in the united states
since uh the second world war you know
in his term we went from seven million
barrels to 11 million barrels
uh um uh in production and the united
states rocketed to being one of the
three great fossil fuel uh
companies in the world so yeah i think
the fracking thing here in the uk is a
bit of a side issue
all right it's funny though you um you
mentioned that quite a lot in your book
how since the coyote years we've led to
a world boom in fossil fuels rather than
the road to a greener one people will
remember obama for his um you know he
was talking about the rising tides in
his inaugural address and yet he
presides over the biggest expansion of
fossil fuels in recent american history
and
so
do you is this your problem with the cop
process then that the words sound very
green but the action is is not i think
the queen put it very well which is
saying that they they talk but they
don't do
well they talk about 250
right
and frankly most of the world leaders
who are there at cop will be dead by
then right and they certainly will have
been elected we've been out of office
except for
um our authoritarians and dictators
around the world but even then they will
be dead by then okay so it's very easy
to sign up to something in 250 just
actually as it's very easy to sign up in
235
and by the way you know the 235 no new
gas boilers is an aspiration
okay well that's several general
elections in the future what we want to
know is how next year and in the next
this decade we're going to stop adding
two parts per million per annum to the
concentration of the carbon the
atmosphere so we want to know what are
we going to do about china what are we
going to do about carbon trade and
carbon imports
um and within that frame how exactly are
we going to step ourselves out of the
fossil fuels so one great thing about
britain or the uk one absolutely
standout success is getting out of coal
okay that the prime minister and others
can truly boast about
but of course if you're going to get out
of coal and you're not going to build a
nuclear very quickly you have to find
some other way of backing it up hence
we're in a gas crisis and it's about
twice as bad as it is in europe and all
those people who are not going to pay a
penny for the transition to
net zero are finding these remarkable
bills landing on their doorstep and wait
till they see what comes in april and
that's where you will the end you do one
or two things right like you get out of
coal but you don't think through
how you practically now do the
transition which includes address the
intermittency
but your proposal is relatively clear
you would like a a carbon pricing or a
carbon tax in other words you'd like
this applied to imports in a way that
would significantly increase the um the
charges we pay for not much of the kits
we buy from china right now
could you do if you're a politician
could you really propose this reveal to
the public how much it would cost reveal
to the public how much it would put
their cost of living up by and then
expect to get elected
so
in my world
first of all domestically we'd apply the
carbon price to agriculture transport
heating oh and um energy
right so for example agriculture is
relatively the largest carbon producer
in britain by a long way
0.5 percent of gdp producing at least 11
emissions
so i'd extend it across the board and
i'd apply it to imports you're
absolutely right the consequence of that
would be that all of us
we the polluters us individually would
have to face the consequence of the
carbon pollution we're causing and that
would make us worse off in the short run
so if you were asking me the question
is it possible for any politician
to tell the truths of the public that
they're living beyond their sustainable
means and they have to adjust to pay the
cost of the pollution they're causing if
your answer that question is no it can't
they can't then don't tell me that
you're at a turning point at cop 26 and
you're going to save the world and this
is the route to addressing climate
change what you're honestly saying is
we are not prepared as your elected
representatives to tell you because
you're not prepared to vote for us
what you would have to do if you really
wanted to address climate change that's
why for all the political capital and
all the rhetoric every single year we
add two parts per million to the carbon
in the atmosphere and we'll do that next
year i have no doubt and i can't see how
we're going to stop doing that through
this decade and you know if you were
wanting to convert an economy from a
peacetime economy to a wartime economy
in the late 1930s you had to tell the
public the truth that a massive
transition of the economy in a short
period was going to cost them and by the
way and i'm not advocating this at all
if you look at the taxation rates that
resulted from that it's extraordinary
but that's because there was an
existential threat you could you had to
fight the battle of britain you had to
have spitfires up there if you look now
there is no immediate extra existential
threat a bit more flooding
it's a bit warmer in summer some people
like that and the winters are a lot
milder nobody actually feels that the
world is falling apart around them and
that's how you get this cake-ism and i
regard cake-ism as the most dangerous
political line to take in addressing our
environmental challenges that we have
now it's wrong
uh i would if i would urge the prime
minister to follow his uh idol churchill
and tell them a bit more about blood
sweat and tears in the sense of tell
them the real cost to doing this tell
the public the truth not try and hide
behind the idea oh it's all fine it's
not going to cost you anything
you can go on flying you can do all this
stuff no hair shirts none of that stuff
just keep smiling and fly from london to
newquay to discuss climate change at the
g7 summit no that's not leadership that
isn't going to work
professor elite helm thank you so much
for
giving us the key to dress and for
discussing some of the the wider issues
we face at cop 26 and in the climate
change debate overall
you